former acting ice director Tom Holman is
here to break it all down Tom you've
been talking about this for years you
have served under Democrats and
Republicans and it doesn't seem like
this Administration cares at all even
though the cartel is Raging patent moves
itself on the back as we speak right now
exactly aren't you and I'm going to talk
about the MS-13 real quick because I ran
an operation against MS-13 in Dallas
Texas 20 years ago and I did a news uh
release that night on TV about the
operation they put a hit on me and my
family the the head of the MS-13 there
what luckily we found him before he
found me then that film you showed to
president Trump house with him on Long
Island we out to operation Matador ice
arrested nearly 500 gang members the
vast majority MS-13 gang members which
really said in this Administration now
you see the criminal arrest by ISIS went
way down because the secretary simply
isn't enforcing immigrants from the
country but gangs are no longer a
priority which is just ridiculous but
the criminal cartels that is a new issue
that's getting bad in the United States
the cartels of Mexico are more violent
now than ever before because they're
fighting over controlled plazas because
you're making more money they've ever
made now they're smuggling women and
children trafficking sex trafficking
women and children they're involved with
Amy smuggling of course drug smuggling
because of this huge immigration crisis
the cartels pushing large groups of
people across the border to create gaps
where there's no borbital agents they've
been pulled off the line and that's when
they move record amounts of drugs so the
violence in Mexico between the cartels
are at an all-time high and now you're
going to see violence in the United
States are rising because now they're
fighting over control of the U.S market
in our major cities so the sad thing is
about the cartel hits United States we
don't know how many people they murdered
because under the UCR uniform a uniform
a uniform form crime report that all law
enforce agency put that into the FBI
doesn't even address cartel murders they
just they just caught them as murder
there's no box to check on the UCR that
it's a cartel hip so we don't even know
how many cartel murders have occurred in
the United States yeah
Tom what do you think needs to be done
right now to secure the Border because
we know what to do
we know what to do we did under
President Trump all they got to do is
just dust off the Trump policies and you
said it earlier you can't have National
Security if you don't have border
security and you can't guarantee Public
Safety if we have an open border 20 of
everybody border patrol arrests are
criminal we got 1.2 million gotaways
there's a reason people want to get away
because they don't want to be
fingerprinted so this country is in bad
shape from criminals coming across that
border record numbers if we don't get
control of it the war is going to be
here on the Homeland then what are we
going to do Tom Holman thanks so much
brother
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else